each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
alright thank you all for coming I'd
like to introduce raluca Papa who is
concluding her internship here after
concluding a very successful
undergraduate period at MIT during which
she published multiple papers at
prestigious conferences so we
anticipated a very successful career
ahead of her starting with this work
she's done with us on cloud computing
hello everyone I'm Luca and this is my
end of internship talk too bad it's
ending so I will talk about enhancing
cloud SLA with security and designing a
secure and practical cloud storage
system so this is work with Helen wang j
large david warner and lee jung so cloud
technology is emerging rapidly and more
and more users are using it the reason
is that it provides more resources such
as more storage also more computation
power it's also more reliable in the
sense that the cloud can provide the
application for you and more available
because the cloud is available from from
different parts of the world as long as
you have connection to the Internet also
it tends to be inexpensive and it's much
easier to buy cloud compute powers than
have your own personal cluster so there
are various use cases for for the cloud
and that's personal storage in which a
user can store his personal file system
on the cloud and that's benefit from the
reliability the cloud provides and also
able is able to share it with his
friends across the world also an enter
enterprise storage because it allows
companies to focus on the target of
their business rather than have to
maintain clusters and pay people for for
various for maintaining such clusters of
computers however the problem is
security so so far in a traditional
computing model we have our data on our
own computers or enterprises yes
okay I'll speak closer to is this better
ok so in traditional evolutional compute
model people store the data on their own
personal computers and as they're the
only one responsible for taking care of
the confidentiality of the date of the
integrity correctness of the data and
the same for enterprises storing the
data on personal personal clusters
however by moving the data in the cloud
the cloud is not the one who can read
the data and thus can control the
confidentiality of the data can modify
the data it can return stale data to the
user by not placing certain updates or
it can discard rights and this can be a
problem because there are bugs or miss
configuration in any software there can
be disc sailors or cloud employees can
be careless they can be curious or they
can be intensively malicious and also
criminals or hackers can get access to
any computer so the problem is that
right now cloud services do not
guarantee security the only guarantee
availability so for example if we look
at the windows azure service level
agreement for computing the user will
have external connectivity at least
ninety nine point ninety five percent of
the time and they also guarantee for
storage correctness of requests at least
ninety nine point nine percent of the
time and they don't mention anything
about security similarly in the Amazon
s3 service level agreement they they
claim that the service will be available
at least ninety nine point nine percent
of the time and for the cases when it's
not they reimburse the client using
their so-called service credit
however because there's no security
guarantees clients with sensitive data
will refuse to place their data on the
cloud numerous clients have expressed
concerns for example this is a concern
regarding widows as you are in which a
user says that it's more dangerous than
you think they say that what the purpose
of Microsoft is to control the data and
to have unfettered access to the date
that read it to find out about the
business model the various people about
the customers to change it and so forth
also similarly about Amazon Amazon
confirms openly that their service is
not pci level 1 compliant and they
recommend not to store credit card
information because they do not provide
any security guarantees therefore our
goals is to enhance a service level
agreement with security guarantees such
as confidentiality integrity freshness
and rights realizability so basically
confidentiality is clear it means that
no one else besides the users that the
customer allows should be able to read
the data integrity means that the
daytime the cloud should be passed
should be some version of the data
placed by the user and not some junk
data that cloud put or some bug cost
freshness means that any route to the
data on the cloud returns the data from
the latest update and writes
realizability means that any update to
the data on the cloud is performed on
the latest update okay so of course
would like this to be efficient and
scalable a specialist if we look at the
enterprise case which has a lot of data
a lot of users lot of group access
control groups and so forth so we have
two main contributions we provide the
security mechanisms needed to enhance a
service level agreement with security
guarantees we also design build and
evaluate the first end-to-end securing
practical storage system okay so I
motivated our work now I will go on
impress and related work our model
security protocols and how we do access
control so there are two kinds of
related work their cloud services and
there's research on secure file systems
and a past or so
case of cloud services there's windows
azure and Amazon s3 for example but as I
mentioned they don't offer any
guarantees regarding integrity freshness
or rights realizability there's another
cloud service Tahoe which is a
peer-to-peer cloud service which
attempts to provide more security
guarantees and in this case the users
can check whether their integrity is
violated however they can detect this
but they cannot prove it this because
there can always be the case a case in
which a client falsely claims that the
cloud to change their data when that
didn't happen also this service doesn't
have a financial contract so if indeed
the cloud because it's peer-to-peer so
indeed if the cloud changes the data of
the client the client no one will pay
the client back for damages also this
system doesn't provide a freshness and
rights utilizability the second part of
the related work is insecure file
systems and data store which is an
extensive literature and contain systems
such as serious Thunder pluto's and so
forth so how are we different well first
besides the fact that we can detect
cloud needs behavior we can prove it
also the cloud can disprove false client
accusations so why do we do this well
because in our case the cloud is a
liable entity and there's a financial
country between the client and the cloud
the client pays for service and the
cloud pays back for damages we also
provide all of confidentiality integrity
freshness and rice realizability and we
are highly scalable so how come we
manage to provide all of the for when
most related work only provides the
first two well we envision the
enterprise scenario in which there is an
enterprise and multiple clients and the
enterprise is trusted by the clients and
can perform some minimal checking in the
case of this previous systems they were
just independent users having some
access to a remote server and not
talking to each other
so your model there are three parties
cloud and enterprise in many clients the
cloud is not trusted for the reasons
that I mentioned before it can change
the data it can return stale data it can
lick the data and so forth the clients
are trusted to do whatever they want
with the data they have access to
because they're allowed to change it but
they may attempt to access data outside
of their access control and outside of
their permissions and they are not
trusted not to do this also they may try
to collude with the cloud to achieve
this goal better price is trusted to
perform membership updates because they
are the employees of the enterprise also
the clients and the enterprise together
are not trusted to not falsely accuse
the cloud of of changing the data okay
so a service level agreement to security
would sound like this if the enterprise
or the user pays a certain amount of
money then the cloud guarantees
integrity freshness rights realizability
with a certain percentage if the cloud
does not meet this then you have to pay
a certain amount of money so know that
we don't mention confidentiality here
because this is entirely controlled by
the clients by just putting encrypted
data in the cloud so now that for this
to make sense yes in the clouds dun dun
dun less movers know what's in the data
but you can say is to look at access
patterns yes what's a military cross
traffic analysis yes I agree that we
don't we don't prevent against that yes
since you do this like an SLA down time
as well as good as a percentage is
inaccessible you're saying that some of
the time the cloud can violate rights to
your lies
and the client that's a key of client
client with it I know percent of the
time you never know what happens is that
the way says so in the cloud does not
meet this they agreed to pay a certain
large amount of money so basically
whenever the client can prove you're
pretty listen maybe I didn't fit
properly so i think what they mean is
the cloud said says okay if you pay this
much money amount of money ninety-nine
percent in time you'll have you'll have
all of the security counties when you
don't have it i'll pay you this back
match back if you pay a bit more than
i'll give you more since that occasion
when you can violate it and that's
really what i mean here is that when you
violated the cloud has to pay back
damages yes lyrics
throwing the way you face it
it's easy for the client to verify the
right satiereal like cereal blazing
teens I so great is relative yes so
we'll get it all of this I will explain
how everything is is verified but the
bottom line is that there is some
auditing going on at enterprise that's
offline that's lightweight and it's easy
to check in that other thing I will
explain it is quite fast anyway so in
order to be able to have such an S
laying under for such an essay to make
sense the customers need to be able to
detect improve clouding his behavior
also the cloud would not provide service
if clients can falsely accuse him of
damages and then get money from the
cloud therefore the cloud needs to have
a way to be able to disprove invalid
client accusations so our solution is
based on sign receipts so at a high
level and then I will explain more
detail the clients and the cloud
exchange receipts every time the client
makes a request the by the receipt when
the cloud returns the receipt to the
client it means that the cloud the cloud
agrees to perform the update that the
client requested order the cloud states
that the request that the response to
read is correct when a client gives a
receipt for a right to the cloud it
means that the client says that yes I
allow this cloud to make this
verification make make make this change
okay so the design principle of our work
is to offload as much of the work as
possible on the cloud but verify so
these are the kind of desired operations
that should be performed in our system
so there's read write operations there's
integrity of freshness and rice
utilizability checks there's access
control of the users their key
distribution are needed for access
control confidentiality and membership
updates and in fact we manage to offload
most of the work for the first four to
the cloud which are the most expensive
ones as I will explain
the clients are the ones performing
confidentiality by only uploading
encrypted data and the membership the
enterprise only gets to do membership
updates climb the vocational client
granting permissions and some
lightweight auditing to verify that the
cloud has properly performed the first
four tasks as we'll see both tests are
done offline and in particular auditing
can be outsourced maybe to a second
cloud or to a cluster and we'll see it's
lightweight and both are inexpensive as
they allow you yes so I said the
enterprise has employees the clients and
some employees are given access to
particular amount of data and some are
not so membership in a sense that who
are the word the members allowed to
access the data access control it but I
just employees
yes access control in the sense that
only certain clients can access the data
on the cloud or not and by membership
here I mean which are those clients that
can do that so the cloud make sure that
whether this kind is valid or not it can
access the data button which are the
enterprises to maintain
welding in taxes control because some
clients aren't should not be allowed to
read it and if they visit yes but
sometimes should below beautiful writing
yes well you both need for both so for
it so if a client has read access he
should be able to get the experience you
should be able to the crib if a client
doesn't have a taxes you should not be
able to get the key and decrypt and for
right axis the same should not be able
to write if he doesn't have access I
guess the question sources keys the
cloud stores keys this is her I will get
it all of this this is just high level
this is Emily's trading how our design
point is is into the system okay I'll
get to all of this okay so first
confidentiality so it's been done in
many previous work each block is
encrypted with a symmetric cipher such
as a yes the client has the clients have
the key and they know the decrypted
value of the block then the cloud only
gets to see the encrypted block and no
key so he cannot decrypt the block okay
integrity again this is similar to
what's been done in previous work the
client now has an additional signing key
that's secret and only the clients with
certain access permissions know it now
this key is used to sign a hash of the
encrypted block and this signature is
given to the cloud now the cloud needs
to ensure that a client cannot make a
modification to a block without
providing a valid signature this is
because later if a client wants to
verify the signature and it's invalid
it's junk it means that the cloud modify
the data the clown won't be able to
produce such a correct signature without
knowing the signing key he can verify
because he knows KP which is the public
key
ok so now I will present the receipts
and how the receipts exchange between
the clients and the cloud goes before i
go into freshness and rice realizability
ok so when a client performs a write
request he has to provide a signed
request a signed receipt to the cloud in
which he says yes I would like you to
make this change overwrite the existing
data and make this change so this
receipt has to contain an old fashioned
a new hash basically saying I'm changing
the data from this state to this new
state now the cloud has to respond with
another receipt signed by the cloud
saying yes I agreed to move this blog
from this hash of the block to this new
hash of the block for read the client
doesn't provide any receipt and the
cloud has to provide a receipt in which
he says yes this is the latest version
of the file it has this hash so it only
contains the current block hash video
has how does a call to verify this
monitor should be authorized in this
I will get the to access control as well
so okay so now how do we do rice
realizability so as I mentioned the rice
realizability means that a right is
performed on top of the latest right so
therefore the cloud must ensure that
updates are performed in the last
version of the data the way he does it
is she looks at the client received and
sees if the old hash of the client reset
corresponds to the current hash of the
block on the cloud means the cloud had
the right version so for example this is
a timeline showing a block which
initially had the hash h1 client day
comes and reads Harrods and the hash is
h1 then client becomes and he reads the
block and the hash is still h101 change
it client becomes and then he wants to
write it so he advances the hash from h1
to h2 client a dozen of the change in he
wants to write block and change the hash
from the previous h1 which he was aware
of to a new age to prime the cloud
should prevent this and should inform
client a that a change has been made
it's up to client a what he does maybe
she merges the versions maybe he
overrides it maybe he takes the old one
but any subsequent great requests that
client amex has to have the new old hash
which is h2 yes why is the requirement
for hash match is a version
you can use the version but that won't
work for later for freshness
I will explain it yes what if the same
data is written twice we wouldn't have
the same match yeah so if it's written
twice and it's the same you mean is the
same content or doing some content sure
well if you should well it turns out
that it's fine if there are cycles in
the hash it will work out theoretical it
works out our auditing will work out
not so sure that it will because can't
you pretend that certain things that
happened it happened so say so let's say
that it's if there's a loop and then
I've gone the next step in the loop ah
you can then remove that step and make
it look as if it never happened you can
remove that step only if you're the only
one updating in the loop if there are
other people in the loop as well they
will be sending as I will explain
receipts to the enterprise for auditing
so you can't just discard those people's
those people's visits those people's
updates I will explain because those
everyone is sending this to the
enterprise for auditing I will explain i
will talk more about that and the
enterprise will see hey dis received is
nowhere this didn't happen and then
something the cloud did something wrong
i will present it okay so freshness so
infestans would like to guarantee that
the rid to a block c is the last right
in order to guarantee freshness we add
the chained hash called CH to each cloud
receipt so the chain hash for a certain
receipt is equal to a hash of the
previous chain hash and concatenated
with the current receipt so the chained
hashes for a certain block the chain
basically what happens is that the chain
hash for a certain receipt is contains
in it information about all the previous
receipt history for that block now the
reason why this gives us freshness and I
will discuss more into it intuitively
the reason is that if a client comes and
perform the rid after a certain right
and the cloud attempts to put the read
before that right giving it stale data
then the chain receipt of the right
won't chain with the read before it
because the person who did the right had
already received the chain reset a long
time ago and that cannot be changed I'll
explain more detail this is an intuition
for now
okay so for example for the client who
is reading right now there's no way the
plan to make sure its suppression
exactly the clients won't check this
until the problem is the talar saying
hey how much balance this car has is it
hundreds of dollars and I get hundreds
of dollars I run away well I'm saying
right well sure but the problem is that
the bank I mean here is we are trying to
prevent the cloud from being malicious
and if the cloud is malicious by saying
you have a lot of money come you know
malicious is just it's about yeah it's a
bug in the cloud and you cannot
guarantee like a boundary it's a fresh
because the client without verified
something like in that scenario like who
to blame blame the cloud that's a bug
it's in the one-percent even those who
mean about us I'm not going to tell you
that well then yeah so basically what
happened to our system all the security
guarantees are checked at the end of the
month and they are proven proven that
they were wrong I'm sure so if you're
not fine with that I know so if you're
not fine with that someone be proving it
at the end of the month you just want to
know every every second and then you
should either decrease the auditing
period and do it all the time good all
I'm just saying this freshness is not
good
yes if you want it in real time you can
do it in real time you can have the
enterprise in real time checking
receipts all the time but it's more
cheaper to do it offline yes so when
you're audited and you find a problem
how do you suffer because you have to
reset all these chains again the circus
is being advised off the party I buddies
let's fix the part of users will be said
to me oh yeah you feel the operation are
you keep the current state so basically
what happened is um you realize the bag
you listen the cloud did something bad
the cloud pays you for damages and you
keep going but that has to be sort of
transactions between the cloud
enterprise in the client have to agree
that yeah that was a bargain now we
still start with me yeah it is it for
the so the enterprise is doing
performing the audits and gets all the
receipts the receipts are proved in
itself across in itself and then Jews
enterprise in the cloud the reconcile
and cloud-based it back for damages of
course if you'd like to roll back then
you should maintain additional state
like logins okay so let's see how the
chain hashes working an example so a
client comes and performs a right right
one and his receipt is for right one and
the chain hash is just the hash of the
Congress it because there is no previous
chain hash ok now another client comes
and perform the read and now the chain
hash is the hash of the current read
receipt and the previous chain hash
which was just a hash all right one
similarly a third client comes and
performed the right and his chain hash
now is the hash of the current ride we
said in the previous chain hash ok so
finally auditing
so the enterprise periodically audits
each block with a certain probability
logs that are more sensitive and
enterprise cares more for them they
should have higher probabilities or they
should have a probability one hundred
percent which means they're consistently
being checked and have food guaranteed
consistency the club doesn't know which
blocks are going to be audited in
certain time okay now for the blocks
that are going to be audited the clients
send receipts back to the enterprise
center it's the ghost from the cloud
back to the enterprise ok so the
enterprise performs the following the
following check it groups the receipts
for each block together then it tries to
arrange the receipts in a sequence such
that the new hash over is it is equal to
the old hash of the of the ax of the
following receipt so for example here I
have three receipts for the same block
two of them are rights because they
advance the hash of the block from the
old one to the new one and the receipt
number three is a read we can see that
they're chained by the value of the
hashes the new hash of the first visit
is equal to the old hash of the second
visit the new hash of the secondary
sheet is equal to the cache of the read
receipt the third receipt ok now the
enterprise has to check that all this
research form only one chain if they do
it means we have rights realizability so
here is why assume that they form
multiple chains that the chain is being
forked and there's a certain client for
who did the right for and send it back
to the enterprise well it must be the
case that either client to work line for
reached the enterprise first rich story
reached the cloud first sent to the
right request first without loss of
generality let's assume that client too
did the right first then he went from
her she be to her she everything is fine
correctly now client for comes and he
wants to perform the right then the
cloud should not have allowed client for
to perform this right and should have
informed him of the client to the update
so here is where rights realizability
was not respected well it is the same
way
uh I mean if it's the same right I mean
you should still we should still send
her i said no but I mean that new hash
is still see right Oh client for client
for clients were inclined to the same
update of the deal the the clouds are
still inform the client because what
client for did this you don't know what
what work she was trying to do he was
just trying to get the state of data in
advance it and maybe if he saw that the
state of data will see he would have
done something else so it's yeah the
cloud should still in form of the change
yes you can talk about sorting to
receive this is a topological sorting
security named as such you don't have a
little date stamp can get very expensive
I agree you should have you should have
sometimes tense you should have some
version numbers in actual implementation
I have because it was it easier to what
also you can use is the fact that these
receipts will pretty much arrive in the
order in which they were generated of
course not the guarantee but that will
help with efficiency because clients
will perform the rites in order to marry
Prince my question when you're very fine
now what do you verify cute so between
those two records the running red
morning yes you're very find that the
hashes and you ash
or do you verify that they are sort of
it recline so what you verify right now
with the enterprise very prices is our
district just one chain if the chain
Forks the cloud was bad so the end or
enterprise wants to see just one chain
because that means a total ordering the
rights means each update so the previous
one and if it's a forking it's bad and
advice logically was not maintained if
there's a gap then the enterprise will
contact the cloud see there's a gap here
maybe some clients timed out in even
send me the receipt you should have the
receipts can you give them to me if you
don't have them you did something bad
you just ripped the hash ok so for
freshness we now look at the attached
chain receipts to chain hashes to these
receipts and we make sure that they also
become in sequence properly so remember
each chain hash or is it with the hash
of the current receipt with the previous
chain hash so there is a so they are
changing ok and now the enterprise needs
to check that the sequence of this chain
hash is the same with the sequence of
them receives from the previous sort and
if this means we have freshness so okay
it's clear why this means it has fresh
nuts because it means that each right
was perform the previous right ok let's
see what happens if the cloud attempted
to to provide stale data so in this case
let's assume that the read in the third
receipt when the client 3 performs the
rid the cloud attempts to give him the
give him the block with hash be as
opposed to the block with hash see well
in this case what would have happened is
that so in this case when the enterprise
checks the sequence it must have been
the case that the chained CH 2 chainz
with ch 3 that CH 2 comes after CH 3
however when climbed to perform the
right to he got a chain hash and he left
then client 3 comes and performs the
right the read but then the cloud can
not to change the scene hai she gave to
client too because she already left
therefore it's not feasible for the
cloud to provide ch3 to the rid such
that the ch2 comes properly after it
unless it finds some collisions in the
hash ok so post auditing the enterprise
in the cloud can throw away the receipts
they're not need anymore they only keep
the last three sheet for each block so
that any subsequent rights or reads can
be made as a continue as a continuation
of the current state of the system and
in order since there can be many blocks
and we don't want the enterprise to hold
a receipt for each block then the
enterprise should just should just
compute a miracle hash and hold the
Merkel hash of the whole system and this
auditing is highly paralyzed able
because basically what enterprises you
just chicks one chain and parts of the
audit of the of the sequence can be
delegated to different threads yes the
earlier the enterprise only was the
portion red light of the block yes so
the enterprise just audits a part of the
blocks each block is given a probability
if the enterprise wants to make sure
that a certain block is always correct
it will always audited let's say I'm
client and yet I keep playing a week or
two later get across already done the
audits that occur in that time here
what happens done so you mean you
complain about the previous auditing
period yeah and you complain about the
blog that was not audited sure well too
bad for you it's like after you may have
one one month later the item you have a
refrain yes too bad yes because
basically if you want to make sure that
your update went through you have to
send a receive the enterprise
yes to the enterprise yes if you just
made the enterprise a chance well sure
but you can I mean if that lock is to be
audited and you want to be lacking how
long is not a period make it one month
to me one day just depends on how much
computation and the price is willing to
get to dedicate how much the enterprise
cares about the data
but basically for the blogs that are
audited within the audit period it can
indeed we have foods a security granted
for the clients that care about the
request and send back the receipts I
mean if the enterprise really cares
about some data it can always order the
blocks
yes we tell us how expensive is our ABCs
yes i will tell you okay so now how do
we do access control and for this i like
to present to cryptography primitives
first that we are going to use the first
one is key rolling introduced by Kevin
phone 2005 so basically what happens is
you start with an initial key and from
that key you can derive subsequent
generations of the kids so he stole
ensures that only a party having a
secret key can for can roll these kids
forward in our case the enterprise only
the enterprise will be able to roll the
keys forward anyone can roll a key
backward if they have a certain
generation of the key so for example if
someone has key a generation 3 it can
generate a generation to Winky and
generation 1 okay so here in the second
one is broadcast encryption which there
have been various methods proposed one
of them is fibernet in 2006 so the idea
is that enterprise can encrypt a message
for a group of clients and any person
any client in that group can decrypt the
message but no one else outside of it
and there's different schemes with
various complexities but I will not get
into that ok so for access control
introduce the notion of a data group
which is basically a group of blocks
with identical access control lists now
each data group has one file in which
there's key information the file is
stored on the cloud so here's what the
file contains it contains a broadcast
encryption of the current generation of
the key we used to encrypt the block so
for example here the key is a generation
I and II I is the key that is used to
encrypt all the blocks in the data group
it's a symmetric key now also it
contains the same as I mention for
integrity used we use a signing key that
is secret to the cloud and the in the
public heat used to verify that the
cloud no
so now we have a broadcast encrypted
version of of the signing key so now
only clients who have write permissions
can decrypt this broadcast encryption
and anyone can see the public key
including the cloud and he uses it to
verify integrity yes can you change the
two new members to the enterprise can
add new members of the group so
basically what happen in price adds new
members of the group it changes this
file it takes a new key or maybe it
gives the same one and broadcasting
crips it for everyone now at all times
need to get this HP now to be able to
decrypt it um they will only get the
kids when they go with the block as I
will explain when they go to okay y'all
xfinity yes brave as you say that kpb
love the client and the client keator
and everything of the car to the craft
was Katie now k peace assistant plain
text in the cloud so um lets him to just
running here
oh yeah I'm so the crew so the cloud has
KP the cloud knows the public key
because he uses he uses it to verify
that clients are even correct form block
so that later the cloud is not accused
of the fact that he changed the blocks
because if ever a client comes and says
can you give me the block and give me
the signed attached that seemed to
attach to it and sees a bogus signature
it cannot accuse the cloud because the
cloud may try to change the blocking it
a piece of public and it's just a sign
of expense and KS and K are known only
to the clients who have access who
should have access to them
yeah so basically the enterprise here
will encrypt ki using broadcast
encryption directed to only the clients
who have read access so only those
clients will be able to decrypt the
broadcast encryption encryption and the
same for the signing key the secret key
is only the clients who have write
access we'll be able to decrypt the
broadcast because the broadcast
encryption was generated for just for
those and this file is a protected is
read only to the clients and it's ND and
it's read right to the enterprise so
basically it's checked using the
mechanisms I described but its audited
all the time for example ok so how do we
do revocation well when a member leaves
the data group the enterprise needs only
to change the data group filed the
enterprise won't go and encrypt all the
other blocks with the new key so
basically it selects a new signing key
and the new public key and it encrypts
the signing key or with the new
membership that has write access control
then it four rolls forward a new
generation of the confidentiality key
used to encrypt the blocks and again
encrypts it only broadcast encrypted
only for those clients that still have
read permissions to it now we have a
list of revocation we approach we have a
lazy revocation approach in which
basically the enterprise's and go and
encrypt all the blocks which the revoke
client has access to what have we
instead just guarantee that any further
changes won't be seen by the client and
basically what happens is when new
clients come up when clients come up
come to check the file kinds i still
have access permissions to the file they
will rien crypt the file with the new
key yes
erase the old encryption right you'll be
the encryption the black secret videos
yes so if the member that you want to
revoke the key for Carruth with the
cloud your screen and so as we say we
adopt laser application that we allow we
just prevent against future changes to
the files not to be seen to the client
but to the revolt client and the
rationale for that is well first
efficiency and second is that well if a
client had access to the blocks you
could have downloaded them right before
but sure just understand not saying yeah
sorry and um I mean of course if you
want to make sure you can just spend
more computation cycles I have the
enterprise we encrypt them that's the
cloud of the chloe races that all
encrypted data for an you contrast there
oh yeah so it's circled yeah okay fine
okay that's it that's a plug in practice
you will leave the confident if you want
to want you to see the data even though
you may download something but it
doesn't mean you still there's maybe
have a huge amount of data I mean you do
download beforehand before you are lay
off or fired then you still can access
all the data even though one year later
that sounds not so into the practical
practical requirements I mean I agree
and we can't trust the cloud too rigid
we can check that later on if you
somehow determine by some other means
that the client still had a copy of it
then you just I mean so the finds a
trade-off right it's a trade-off because
you just let go I mean if this woke
right because you want to have this
backward compatible so that any
agri have access to those files and they
have decrypted by that's that's a
trade-off well I think the trade-off
comes in place by the pilot the stores
on the cloud because the cloud can
always keep all versions of the data and
we can't stop him from doing that so
just probably create a trust model Oh
maliciousness interest mode but
understood here you're paying in SLA and
if you suddenly soon as maliciousness
well then things like persistence can be
guaranteed between one operator to take
bribes to drop the latest version your
file and Amazon's happy a few thousand
dollars you've lost your billion dollar
objection I just tacking on the
maliciousness aspect that I've seems
like there are these other guarantees a
point yes you might not be able to do
about it yes and I agree with the fact
that we don't like we don't necessarily
think of a cloud that's in candidly
malicious because the cloud would go out
of business really soon
I can argue that but anyways if the
cloud is absolutely intently intently
malicious who wants to be bad if the
company's goal then yeah we persistent
data is we can prevent against that the
cloud can just make a copy and a use of
used to have access to it and still have
access to
and that's I think interacting outs
outsourcing out storing outside of your
clusters ok so the receipt as I
mentioned the receipts served to prove
cloud misbehavior or disprove invalid
client claims as I discussed however
there's a problem because this resist
need to be exchanged in an
all-or-nothing fashion here's why so
assume that a client wants to make a
right and he gives the cloud or is it
the cloud times out and he doesn't send
the cloud receipt back to the client
then the cloud has still he has the
right receipt from the client and he can
choose to apply the change or not
whatever he chooses his backed up
because he has the proof that the client
requested that change also if we'd go
the other way around in which the cloud
sends the right we sit first and then
the client needs to sign it after and
the client says oh I timed out I didn't
send it when the client has the cloud we
sit and he cannot use the cloud so for
example if the cloud the cloud doesn't
know what to do because he didn't get
the client visit he can either apply the
data or not if he doesn't apply the data
then the client can accuse him hey
saying hey he gave me this receipt that
we said he said he agreed he will apply
it but if or if the client the cloud
does apply the data does apply the
change then the client can accuse him
saying I never asked him to make this
change he doesn't have a receipt from me
so I never asked him therefore this
resist need to be changed in the no need
to be exchanged in an all-or-nothing
fashion and there are cryptographic
primitives for this like fair exchange
by Macaulay in 2006 the problem with
this one is that it invokes an untrusted
party whenever whenever a problem occurs
when I know the party doesn't send the
receipt and that's not very efficient
because it can happen that clients time
out so we adopt adopted change solution
which is in which the cloud does send
the receipt first then it waits for the
client to answer if the client isn't
answered the cloud context enterprising
can you please annul his right request
so if a client sends a write request
then the cloud sends back the receipt
but he doesn't get the receipt from the
client she waits for a while and if he
doesn't get it costs enterprising
analogy okay so I've presented our
protocols now I will go and put an
implementation evaluation and we'll
conclude so I implemented the system in
about five thousand lines of C sharp
just for our code of course this runs on
top of some a drawer storage client and
also uses some other external code so
the way I sure works I don't know how
many of you are familiar is it has two
kinds of roles as web rows which have
which can contact which can talk to
outside parties under the internet and
work roles which don't have access to
the Internet the web browse don't scale
I think the limit right now is to web
rose I mean definitely stew I don't know
if they're going to scale it but the
purpose of the worker role is for
scalability and if they can be a large
number of workers can be deployed
currently it's still too because as
reason isn't early I mean stages there
are some tokens that allow you to have
25 but they don't fully work always but
anyways soon they will be able to deploy
much more worker old then there is a
storage which is in the form of blobs
cools and tables we are only going to
use blobs and Q's here and the means of
communication between the web role and
the work role are is through storage so
here is how a typical write request
let's say with the work in our system so
the client performs an HTTP request to
the web row of the page loads and the
web replaces this request in a queue on
which the workers are waiting now a
worker picked up the request from the
queue that's some processing maybe he he
worked he gets some blogs from storage
and then I want to see once his
has the result he places it in a blob in
an answer blob on which the web web
roads are waiting so basically to web
role tells the client in which blob to
put the result once the weblog got the
result packet send it back to the client
so the end the storage and the web rolls
are not necessarily in the same stored
in the same data center okay so here is
for example the average read latency for
the no security for the just
confidentiality in the full security
case we can see that for no security
it's 0.6 seconds it's kind of high
however we will see that throughput is
good and it's kind of high because
storage and work roles are not
necessarily co-located and there's all
these round trip times between client
work rolls storage and so forth maybe in
future releases that it's going to be
more efficient for confidentiality which
is what it was which is the lightest for
my security people usually have nowadays
it's slightly higher and for full
security it's about 0.1 seconds above
confidentiality and this is not
necessarily because of the cryptography
but it's more because of the fact that
the client visits are each stored in a
blob so that the cloud backs up the
receipt she gets from the clients in
case the enterprise had seen for so he
stores the mini blob I could do improve
performance by patching multiple
recipients throwing them in the same
block because every access to the blob
storage take some time yes
um you read and write no i mean like
that if I encryption decryption right if
you have to do something I'll on the
client side on the server side promenade
service' other clients I have to encrypt
a huge file if it glove is a huge then a
certain will increase the latency if
it's a very small it will decrease I
agree on the other if the flowers too
small they are way too many receipts
that's true what we do is we just have a
typical 4k a blob store and it's true
that for a larger blob Dover had a
crypto likes one receipt and it must
monitoring it's actually I think more
and more it's actually saving efficiency
because throughput as well see is good
just latency is slightly too much
because of all these round trips so for
rights we know security we have 0.7
seconds and with full security would
have 1.1 seconds this is again because
we store more receipts in that case and
I'll yeah I i will try to look into like
matching them and not accessing blob
stories often yes no contention
this is write latency so yeah it's
terminal contentious this is just one
client doing 100 rights and checking
damage but they're not patched like one
after the other when one finishes are
the other one are you shrink yourself
okay uh yes this is secretly time is you
encrypt the walkway he could including
the confidentiality and food security
not a no security there is no such thing
no question okay so first to put but
this is a large file a 20 megabytes
ascent and so we can see that for no
security it's about 4.4 megabytes per
second throughput confidentiality is
slightly less in full security it's also
slightly less about four megabytes per
second so the difference is not that
high write throughput is slower and
that's because of writing blobs is lower
so we can see that no securities about
370 kilobytes per second and with full
security about 3 40 kilo bytes per
second so basically the bottom line is
that adding the security to our system
doesn't encourage costs according to the
baseline I mean based compared to the
based on the other hand just like your
network Piper to the house to the cloud
storage is so narrow the same saying its
own
without anything only achieved for 300
yes whatever is just I mean I'm sure
they're gonna improve it it's second
very early stages and it's not even
feeling right now if you realized that
if the number of pipe is so narrow when
you see your differences worse more than
the same much he wants you to redo this
experiment then you only look at the
server don't think I'm not even though
because missing it I mean I just wanna
say that the laners you give our last
advance a lot of information but swoop
you to make an dinero hi bata bernero I
see all the difference is really small
the same but your security
confidentiality you don't actually write
your rate could just being you don't
actually have to do these serial aid
because you're just you're just writing
data so you could send it all at once
and get rid of all that latency and have
a better throughput number with these
are you are you waiting for the response
before you do the neck spray so this is
just one large file right
extent all at once it's sent all at once
so it's be going into it takes ok so
that is the Autobots get written in
parallel basically uh so what happens at
the blob storage level I mean what I do
is I I do know there are certain stick
Marshall India suggest that you created
resist there oh I created I mean all I I
use my storage system and I sent one big
file and I put it into storage yeah the
story
uh remotely on the cloud centuries did
you measure cpu utilization
traditionally for performance we don't
care but modern data center servers
green energy air conditioning power
consumption blah we care so I didn't
really measure it but later I have some
results me to have multiple threads on
the same worker and since they are quite
parallel i would say that there isn't
that much high cpu utilization yeah i
didn't matter i will look into it yeah
just doing straight unencrypted rookies
reason rice isn't gonna hurt that not
touch the cpu much at all just take the
data shoving it to disk encryption is
going to impose a lot more cpu / yes i
did not look but anyways here is so
basically what this was to say is that
if the block size is larger you can have
better performance because i write this
file all at once in one blob so I don't
write it I don't split it in blocks in
and write them separately anyways so
this shows the scaling the number of
workers as i mentioned unfortunately i
could only get two workers because as
you're currently puzzling it for a user
account however i try to have like a 24
34 threads for each worker and I
measured the number of requests per
second is increasing number of workers
and we can see that even though I only
go to about 8 threads um it's it looks
like it's scales linearly so auditing
performance so this graph shows the
running time is depending on the number
of your seats this is just one thread
going through the chain over States
trying to audit them and i put the axis
in logarithmic on both sides because the
numbers were getting too large and i
could you could you would only see the
one point uh yes overhead as a fraction
the overhead to actually do the two data
with the writing so ever you're doing if
you're consuming x resources a month
what's the fraction attacks that you're
out in this consumer intuition for that
I don't think is that high because one
blob for one blob auditing solitude 22
consequence rights 21 club is in the
order of micro seconds so I think so for
example one hundred thousand one hundred
million receipts I going to take four
minutes to audit in one thread and I'm
assuming that maybe one block will only
have about 1000 changes in a month or
maybe let's say 10,000 or 100,000 and
that still will be you I know about 10
seconds told you that blob in a month so
I don't think it's I don't think it's a
significant amount but yeah it's some an
interesting experimental to Rand
University
you'll get the restoring yes
anyway so I also looked at the
paralyzing auditing and I I don't know I
didn't produce a graph but it looks
linear and we'll put it in a subsequent
paper so do you have an intuition why
wouldn't well yeah I mean there's still
some setup I mean among the feds yeah
it's it's leaner it's proof of concept
you have was busy to check some
signature literacy do something why it
should
when we see them the issue more would
lie to me yes and it's there but it's a
proof of concept I mean yes I mean I
guess there's still some you know part
of just one person does and that
supporting chunks for different threads
and then the threads go on and audited
okay so in conclusion we provide a
security enhanced SLA and we provide a
novel secure cloud storage system that
provides confidentiality integrity right
supplies ability and freshness and it's
callable to the enterprise size we are
also looking on search but I did not
include it here because was too much
material thank you if like you list the
Marvel poverty's you have an intuition
like each one as long lasting term
performance that you need to drop I mean
yeah so people want to talk which one
will do draw to save all this well
rights realizability and freshness kind
of happened together because they need
the visits so if you drop the truth then
you don't have the receipts and you
don't have the only thing anymore either
so confidentiality and integrity are do
is just to achieve but the problem then
is that you don't have fresh rights
and your fresh wit and rights so yeah
the most expensive are the last two I
think they're about the same because you
need every season so listen to apply
stores on structure the neighbors for
miles
to extract the data problem doesn't
protect a structure so you can protect
individuals well I mean you can protect
the file user table restored but like
some connection between various files
like consistency between various files
we don't have that because we tre the
files independently and just because
which were the files independently we
allow concurrent updates which gives us
scalability if you want them to be if
you want them to be together like if you
want them to be consistent with each
other then you should fit them basically
like one file in terms of receipts like
all receipts for the two blocks need to
be serialized so that does the change
you need to do as opposed of having just
one chain of research for each block you
should have one change of receipts for
the two correlated blocks together so
yes concrete model if the cloud is
Michael pursue and the client is joe the
plumber whose enterprise okay so what
happens is so we look at enterprise like
a startup company so the enterprise is
the startup company like a bunch of
servers on the end of life the employees
so this targets that this is I mean I'm
one of our main goals is scalability for
huge companies who'd like to store their
data in there and they have a lot of
employees and its color black is
controlling yeah enjoy the quiet right
spot the start-up supposed to be
identified this isn't
sure they can be startup customers can
we start up employee employees basically
like okay what startup employees another
than the customers as well then the
customers as well but anyway if you
would like to apply this to the personal
storage case you can and enterprise is
the owner and the people who with whom
he shares the file or the the employee
the clients here oh yeah the total net
worth friends
you